as it is supposed to be a weekend to
honor our nation's bravest but Memorial
Day turning into Mayhem in some places
instead a mob of teenagers unleashing a
brutal attack on a group of off-duty
Marines in California this graphic that
this video is very graphic watch here
[Music]
the Marines say that they were just
enjoying the beach when they asked a
group of teens to stop light enough
fireworks after getting hit by debris
that then led to the altercation where
the men were jumped and repeatedly
stomped on violence spilling out in
other parts of the country as well nine
people were shot including three
children on a boardwalk in Florida and
Chicago turned into a war zone at least
53 people were shot 11 of them killed
making it the deadliest weekend the
windy city has seen in eight years and
that was despite efforts to prevent it
the state had deployed 30 yellow vested
peacekeepers to help suppress violence
didn't work and newly elected left-wing
mayor Brandon Johnson was touting money
and even promised that things would be
safe ahead of the weekend
this weekend the soul of Chicago will be
on display for residents families and
visitors your safety is my top priority
and to that end our Public Safety
agencies have plans in place for the
weekend and summer months to ensure that
everyone can enjoy our city in peace I
really want to make sure that the full
power of city government is out this
weekend keeping everyone informed safe
and busy
judge will let you kick us off today on
all of that you know uh I have to tell
you Dana I am so
flabbergasted that these people believe
that defunding the police as this mayor
mayor new mayor in Chicago believed is
the answer and when he says we want to
show off the the soul of Chicago and put
it on display and we're going to have
the full power of city government your
fools you're all fools the only thing
that we need the full power of His law
enforcement to stop crime and these
Progressive these regressives they go
back to trying to reinvent the wheel
trying to figure out what they can do to
protect people the deadliest weekend in
terms of homicides Memorial Day weekend
in eight years two two-year-olds shot I
mean it just is it's it's it's it's wild
and this yellow jacket nonsense 30 of
them are going to take care of three
million people two-thirds of those three
million people believe that Public
Safety is the number one issue and
you've got 30 Yellow Jackets one of
which is involved in a crime himself as
a criminal charged with three felonies
do you even vet these people
look we are now at a point when
fools who know nothing about law
enforcement are trying to stop crime
they don't know how to do it God help us
going forward Jesse I want to comment on
either the Florida shooting or the the
Marines who got attacked in California
well Jordan Peterson one of his 12 rules
for life is you don't
bother children while they're
skateboarding okay so if I'm at the
beach and I see a bunch of children
skateboarding or lighting off fireworks
I'm not going to run head first into a
group of 50 kids doing whatever it is
they're doing I'm not saying they
deserve to get beat obviously they
didn't but you got to know when to cool
your jets the peacekeeping program is a
Democrat ground game here's how it works
it's an 11 million dollar program to
fund 500 peacekeepers each Peacekeeper
gets paid a hundred dollars
Dana where's the rest of the 11 million
dollars going someone's getting the
money because it's not going to the
peacekeepers the peacekeepers throw on a
yellow jacket and their ex-gang members
and they go smoke cigarettes while the
bullets whiz by
and then you're gonna say that you're
reducing harm
you're basically paying people on the
street every five years to get the votes
together that's how this works and it's
11 million this year and then next year
it goes to 30 million dollars so that's
how they say they're going to reduce
file it's not going to reduce violence
at all the mayor actually throughout the
first pitch in Chicago and I have to say
I think the guy's an idiot and he's
going to get people killed and you vote
for more shootings you get more
shootings that's what democracy looks
like the guy's a good arm and he threw a
heater right over the center of the
plate on Memorial Day weekend that I
respect everything else that is an
absolute disaster Jesse if you're on the
beach and you got hit by fireworks you
wouldn't say anything I would be
participating in the fireworks all right
um okay thank you Harold for junior but
you comment on that there's also the
problems in Hollywood Beach Florida
where apparently it was by an eyewitness
account that we interviewed this morning
on America's Newsroom said it was
younger men on feet like teenagers they
thought and they only had one person in
custody
it's an epidemic thanks again for uh
having me around the table it's an
epidemic National you see in rural New
Mexico you see this happening uh
obviously Hollywood we're one year
anniversary of Uvalde I think I think
the the the the judges on to something
and has been as we all have been around
the table I think when strategies are
run on by political officials and they
they win and they Implement those
strategies and they don't work be it
public safety be it education be it
climate change be it anything
it is it would behoove an elected
official to switch and change to your
point I'm glad he has a nice arm but it
appears that some of the strategies and
he's only been in office a little bit of
time I'm hoping he's evaluating
everything that's going on because we
need more police on the streets without
question if we have to find ways that I
I respect mayors that would come to
Washington saying I need more money to
pay police officers and to train them
and to give them more incentives to be
police officers too we need more
technology to track this violence where
where it's the highest and where it's
the worst in areas I was on the phone
with a dear friend in Detroit a little
while ago as he was saying the mayor
there is implementing innovative ways in
which to try to track the violence to
ensure that even before the police are
called the police are dispatched there
because the red lights have this
technology showing where gunfire and
where activity may be government judge
you may know some of those things three
I think we have to begin in effort to
seriously track or be able to account
for certain guns because I've said
before guns find their ways into places
where you don't find good education and
other things but my bottom line I think
you have to listen to the judge on this
one I think sometimes she can be a
little partisan with it but you're right
we need law enforcement and we need more
of it in many of these areas because
you're not going to prevent or
discourage or dissuade people from
committing these crimes if there's no
accountability and if there's no police
presence I agree with you there yeah
but that didn't have guns that beat down
those three Marines but if there were
police officers on that beach yeah that
might not have happened we agree there
was just to the point about money isn't
the only answer Greg there was a Teo
Hardiman from Chicago was on Newsroom
this morning told Bill hemmer about how
the policies actually need to change as
well in addition to more police and more
money watch here
the gun violence that took place over
the Memorial Day weekend it's just it's
a regular you know it's a the average
day in Chicago no one has the fear the
police anymore people don't feel that
like they're going to be caught if they
break the law Criminal Justice Reform
has backfired on the victims here in
Chicago the police can only do so much
we have policies in Chicago where the
police cannot Chase somebody in the car
they cannot chase you on foot some of
them policies need to be reversed right
now in order to get the job done here in
Chicago that's right that was also
replicated in places like San Francisco
and L.A yeah I think we need a Criminal
Justice Reform reform because uh
Criminal Justice Reform focuses on on
enhancing the edge that the criminal has
on their victims if you look at
everything it's it's based on this
Twisted version of fairness that you are
supposed to treat the criminal as fairly
as you treat the victim that's not how
it works but you don't have to imagine
creating laws that increased your
likelihood of getting eaten by bears
right because that's more fair to Bears
that's what's happening to people right
now we've increa we've changed the rules
of the game so it's easier for victims
to become victimized and I've got even
though I do understand I understand
Jesse's point about you know if kids are
playing for fireworks uh you know on
Memorial Day probably should just let it
be but we have a weird disconnect with
the word team and I've had it a group of
teens doesn't make it any less dangerous
than a group of adults in fact they're
more dangerous because their brains are
mush right you don't have a fully free
fully formed brain and tell you what
you're 25. so they're like Monsters
teens are monsters and when you put them
into the group they are like a swarm and
it doesn't matter to the victim if she's
killed by a 33 year old or a 13 year old
it'd say well at least it was a child no
we've been protecting teens for so long
because if their age I think you need to
start charging them as adults for
violent Act
and I I mean sure if they're shoplifting
stuff like that but I I I we have seen
this by the way in Chicago
the perps are as young as the victims
and everybody goes it's teens on teams
it's yeah it's because we're letting the
teens go we we don't let people know
their past right because it happened
before they were 18. we're creating
fallacies out of this reform we expect
the target market is going to cheer us
as conquering Heroes when we do reform
that's not the case all those dads that
went away to jail they didn't come back
and become fathers of the year we need a
war on teens is what you're saying I'm
ready to take the war to the beach and
take their firecrackers I actually have
the foot pursuit protocol it has 11
pages long in Chicago here's what you're
not allowed to do if you're pursuing
someone as a police officer you have to
stop the pursuit if they enter a
building a structure a confined space an
isolated area or a dense or difficult
terrain crazy
or if there's inclement weather you have
to immediately stop Incredible or if
there's Darkness you have to call off
the pursuit or if it's steep terrain or
if there's a worn out structure or if
there's a pile of debris
so if you're if you're being chased by
the police run towards any of those
things right you're good if you see a
pile of debris right dive on it and the
police just sat there that's right walk
away in Chicago it's unbelievable I want
to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now